Now let's take a look at
the Phase I of another protocol.
The purpose of this phase is to
establish a security association, so
that it can be used
to establish multiple
IP security associations in Phase II.
In Phase I, both sides negotiate
the protection to be used.
For example, Or ESP.
And agree on the crypto
algorithms to use.
For example, AES and HMAC with SHA1.
Then they establish a shared secret key.
For example,
they can use the Diffie-Hellman key
exchange protocol to prevent
man-in-the-middle attack, or
generally to authenticate
the shared secret.
Both sides can use either a pre-shared
key or digital signatures or
public-key encryption to
authenticate the key exchange.